PROFESSOR: For a
couple of lectures,
we're going to be discussing
now the hydrogen atom.
So you've seen the
hydrogen atom before.
You've seen it in 804.
You've seen it in 805.
Why do we see it again in 806?
Well, the hydrogen atom is a
fairly sophisticated example.
It's the harmonic oscillator
of atomic physics.
If some of you are going
to be doing atomic physics,
eventually, you have to
understand the atom perfectly
well, the energy levels, the
degeneracies, why are they,
how do you separate
the levels, how
do you split the degeneracies.
It's a fantastically
good example
of perturbation theory,
our degenerate perturbation
theory, non-degenerate
perturbation
theory in some cases.
But overall, it's a very
important physical system
that affects many
areas of physics,
astrophysics with
hyper fine splitting,
all kind of processes in
atomic physics and lasers,
and things like that.
So it's something we really
want to understand well.
And this time in 806, it's
the right time for you
to understand the fine
structure of this atom.
Bits and pieces of this
have been done before.
But now, we're going
to do it in detail.
So let's start with hydrogen
atom fine structure.
Hydrogen atom fine structure.
That is the main topic
for a couple of lectures.
So in terms of
Hamiltonians, we've
been talking of an unperturbed
Hamiltonian, an H0.
This Hamiltonian is known.
It's the momentum squared over
2m minus e squared over r.
Here, this is the momentum
in three dimensions.
It's a three-dimensional
system, of course.
This m is the mass of the
electron times the mass
of the proton, divided by
the mass of the electron
plus the mass of the proton.
And that's the reduced
mass of the system,
but it's approximately equal
to the mass of the electron.
So we will--
whenever we write m,
it will be the mass
of the electron.
Now, if you happen to have a
nucleus with z protons, what
you have to do is replace
this e squared by z e squared.
And this is because
the factor of e
squared comes from the
product of the charge
of the electron times the
charge of the nucleus.
So if the charge of the
nucleus becomes z times bigger,
this e squared is
replaced by this quantity.
What important length
scales exist here
is the bore radius is the
most important length scale,
and it's constructed with
the quantities that appear
in this Hamiltonian and H bar.
So in particular, doesn't
involve the speed of light.
There's nothing in this
system that is relativistic.
So this quantity is h
squared over m e squared.
And that this has
units of length
is something that you
should be able to derive
from here in a few instance.
Please make sure you
know how to derive it
without having to count mass,
length, time units here.
This is something you should
be able to do very quickly.
One piece of
intuition, of course,
is that the e appears in the
denominator, which is intuition
that as the strength
of electromagnetism
is made smaller and smaller
by letting e goes to 0,
the orbit of the electron
would be bigger and bigger.
So this is about 53
picometers, where a picometer
is 10 to the minus 12 meters.
A nice unit.
It's half an angstrom,
roughly, but picometers
is the right unit for
people that think of atoms.
Then the energy levels are given
by minus e squared over 2a0 1
over n squared.
This is a beautiful formula
in terms of quantities
that you understand.
First, the energy just depends
on n, and this 1 over n
squared.
And n is called the
principle quantum
number, principle
quantum number,
and it goes from
1 up to infinity.
This has units of
energy, and that's
why this is nice,
because e squared over
r is the units of potential
energy in electromagnetism.
So when you see this,
you know that this
has the right units of energy.
And for the ground
state of hydrogen,
n equal 1, that energy
is about minus 13.6 eV.
Now, in terms of thinking
ahead for perturbation theory,
some of the
perturbation theory here
will reflect the fact that
electromagnetism is weak,
and the other fact will reflect
that the electron is actually
moving with slow velocities.
So let's see these two things.
First, we can write
the energy, or in terms
of defined structure constant.
So alpha, which is defined
structure constant.
This e squared over [? hc, ?]
the units we're working with.
And it's about 137.
So whenever you see
e squared over a0,
which is a unit of energy,
you should realize that--
if you wanted to change
that, for example,
for the case that you have
a nucleus with z protons,
you cannot just do e
squared going to ze squared,
because in fact, a0,
itself, has an e.
So don't think that the
energy depends like e squared.
It actually depends more
like e to the fourth times
other constants.
So let's do that.
So we have here m e
to the fourth over h
squared, using the value of a0.
And then we can use e to the
fourth from this equation.
So it would be alpha m
alpha squared h bar squared
c squared over h bar squared.
And it's equal to alpha
squared mc squared.
A nice way of thinking
of the ground state
energy of the hydrogen
as a small quantity alpha
squared times the rest
energy of the electron.
After all, the system begins
just with an electron,
and it has some rest
energy, and there
should be a natural
way of expressing this.
Of course, you start
seeing this c squared here.
But the c squared
really is nowhere there.
We've put it for convenience.
But it allows us
to think of scales,
and in particular, the
rest mass of the electron
is alpha is much bigger,
because alpha squared is about 1
over 19,000.
1/137 squared is about that.
So the energy, en, can
be written in a way
that we will use often as
minus 1/2 alpha squared
mc squared 1 over n squared.
All right.
And another observation, the
momentum of the electron, we
could estimate it
to be h bar over a0.
So this is me
squared over h bar.
And we use the e
squared for what it is.
So this is alpha.
Well, I'll put m,
alpha hc over h bar.
So this is alpha mc.
It's a nice thing, alpha mc.
It says that the momentum
that you could construct
relativistically, the
mass of the electron
times the velocity, you
still have to divide by 137.
But it's clearer if you write
it like m alpha c, and then
momentum, which is mass
times velocity, at least
for slow velocities.
Now is mass times alpha times c.
So the approximate velocity
that we estimate on the electron
is c over 137.
So that's very nice.
It's kind of non-relativistic.
OK.
So this is the basic things.
But the most important
stuff is really
getting the table of
how the atom looks.
So this is still review.
Half of this lecture,
in a sense, is review.
We put here, not in scale,
n equals 1, n equals 2,
n equals 3, and n equals 4.
In reality, the hydrogen
atom, if this is 0 energy,
and this is the ground state,
the ground state that's here,
the second excited state
is here, the third is here,
the fourth is here, fifth,
they all accumulate here.
But that I've
written it this way.
Now, we'll have l
equals 0 here, l
equals 1, l equals
2, l equals 3.
And there is another
notation for this state.
I don't know why, but there is.
A capital l that
is a function of l.
So capital l of l
equals 0 is called s.
So these states are
called s states.
Capital l of l
equals 1 is called p.
So states with l equal
1 will be called p.
Then d and f.
These are names.
We'll use those names.
They're OK.
And here are the states.
For n equal 1, there's
just one state here.
And here there's
one state as well.
But for n equal 2, there
is a state with l equal 0,
and there is a state
with l equal 1.
For n equal 3,
there's 0, 1, and 2.
For n equal 4, there's
0, 1, 2, and 3.
So these are the states in the
spectrum of hydrogen, something
that we should know very well.
And what are the patterns here.
They're degeneracies.
Why?
Because when we talk l
equal 2, for example,
that means a multiplet
of angular momentum
with total angular momentum 2.
And that comes with as
azimuthal angular momentum
that goes from minus 2 m to
plus 2, that is five states.
So in principle, each bar here
is five states, five states.
l equal 1 has m equal
1, 0, and minus 1.
So three states, three
states, three states.
And here, really zero states.
So there's lots of degeneracy.
That's why we spend
lots of time studying
degenerate perturbation
theory, because this gigantic
degeneracies here.
So to determine the
origin or the way
we parametrize the
degeneracy, there's
just one formula
that says it all.
And that formula
is degeneracies.
It's the formula
that explains it all,
and it says that the
principle quantum
number is equal to capital
n plus l plus 1, where
n is the degree of a polynomial
in the wave function.
Wave function.
l is the orbital
angular momentum.
So this says, for example, that
this degree of the polynomial n
can be 0, 1, 2.
It cannot be negative.
l can also be 0, 1, and go on.
But here, for example,
you see the main rule
that for a fixed n, you
can have l equals 0 1, 2,
up to n minus 1,
because by the time
you take l equals to n
minus 1, this whole thing
is equal to little n,
and capital n is 0.
And that's as far as you can go.
So the angular momentum cannot
exceed the principle quantum
number minus 1.
That is what we see
here for n equal 3.
You can have up to l equal 2.
For n equal 4, you can
have up to l equal 3.
So this is kind of well known.
Now, for each l,
each l, you have
m from minus l all
the way to plus l.
And that's 2l plus 1 values.
So the degeneracy at n, at
the principle quantum number
equal n is the sum from l
equals 0 up to n minus 1.
Those are all the
possible values
of l of the number of
states in each l multiplet.
And you've done this one
before, and that actually
turns out to be equal
to n squared, which
says there should be
four states at n equal 2,
indeed one state for S equals
0, three states here is 4, 1, 3,
5.
It's that property that the
sum of consecutive odd numbers
comes up equal to the
square, a perfect square.
It's a very nice
thing geometrically.
So the wave function--
we'll write it here-- the
wave function psi mlm.
These are our quantum numbers
and principal quantum number.
Once you know n, you know
the sum of capital N plus l.
But l is a little
more physical than n.
So we'll use l, and
once you know l,
you still need to know where a
given state, which value of m
you have.
So those are your
three quantum numbers,
and this wave function goes
like a constant times r over a0
to the l times that polynomial
we spoke about, 1 plus beta r
to the r over a0 all the way
up to a number times r over a0
to the capital N times e to
the minus r over n a0 times
ylm of theta and phi.
So that's your wave function.
Those numbers I
have not determined.
I have not determined
the normalization.
But if you're looking
at the wave function,
the easiest place to see
the principal quantum number
is here.
The easiest place to see
the orbital angular momentum
is here.
You identify it from here.
It must be multiplying
a polynomial that
begins with 1, because the
leading power in the solution
must be r to the l,
and has degree n here.
And the m quantum number you see
it from the spherical harmonic.
So in particular, here
you have a state with l
equals 0, n equal 1.
So this must have n equals 0.
This must have n
equals 1, because you
must get to 2 with a capital N
and l equals 0 and a 1 there.
So this is n equal 1.
This would be n
equal 2, n equal 3.
Similarly here, n equals
0, n equals 1, n equals 2,
n equals 0, n equals
1, n equals 0 here.
The n's decrease in this
direction as l increases,
keeping the sum of capital
N and l constant and equal
to little m minus 1.
Interestingly, this
makes sense as well.
If you may remember, the
quantum number N, capital N,
tells you the number of
nodes of the wave function,
because a polynomial of
degree n can have n zeros,
and therefore,
this wave function
has no nodes, one node,
two nodes, three nodes.
The number of nodes increase.
That's another thing that
wave functions should have.
So a couple more
comments and this.
We'll write-- I'll write the
ground state wave function.
I'll put it here.
I'm cluttering
things a little bit.
But the ground
state wave function
is one that we can have
and normalize easily.
Square root of pi over a0
cubed e to the minus r over a0.
That's the ground
state wave function.
OK.
Comments on this thing.
First, there is a very
large degeneracy here.
And it has a nice
interpretation.
This correspond to states with
different values of the angular
momentum.
Semi-classically, if you
were doing Keplerian emotion,
and think semi-classically
of the electron orbit,
all the orbits here
corresponds of orbits
of the electron with the
same semi-major axis,
but with different eccentricity.
So as it turns out,
the orbit with least
l is the most eccentric
of all orbits.
And as you go in this
direction, the orbit
becomes more and more circular.
So if you want an
immediate intuition,
as to why are all these
states distinguishable,
it's because they are orbits
with different eccentricity.
There are ellipses with
different eccentricity,
all with the same
semi-major axis.
So it could be a
circle like that,
or it could be just
an ellipse like that.
So those are it.
Then, most important
complication we've
ignored here, it's the
spin of the electron.
Electron has spin.
So we know the spin
of the electron
represents a degree
of freedom described
by a two-dimensional
vector space.
So there's two states
in every one of this.
So we will have
to consider that.
And if I want to put the
number of states on each one,
here there was
one state we said,
but now we know there
are really two states.
And here, there's two
states is l equals 0, two
states, two states.
Here is l equal 1.
That's three configurations
of orbital angular momentum.
But the electron has, again,
up or down possibilities.
So these are six states,
six states, six states.
l equals 2 is five states,
but with the electron,
there is 10 states
and 10 states here.
In this one, l equals 3
is 7 states, 2l plus 1,
but with the electron degrees
of freedom is 14 states.
So these are the right
number of states.
When we'll do the
fine structure,
we'll have corrections due
to the spin and corrections
due to relativity.
Both things will
make our corrections.
And by the time we
do that, we may also
want to explore the
atom by putting it
in an electric field.
That's the stark effect.
It will change energy
levels, and you learn more
about the energy
levels of a system.
You can put it in
a magnetic field,
and that's a Zeeman effect.
And the magnetic field can
be weak, or it can be strong,
and it's a different
approximation,
and there's several things
we have to do with it.